first I want to update you on the latest
data on the coronavirus response two
million four hundred and eighty nine
thousand five hundred and sixty three
tests for corona virus have now been
carried out in the United Kingdom
including one hundred and thirty six
thousand four hundred and eighty six
tests carried out just yesterday two
hundred and forty thousand one hundred
and sixty one people had tested positive
that's an increase of three thousand
four hundred and fifty-one cases since
yesterday ten thousand four hundred and
eighty four people are currently in the
hospital
we've coronavirus down from twelve
percent from eleven thousand eight
hundred and seventy two this time last
week and sadly of those tested positive
for corona virus across all settings
thirty four thousand four hundred and
sixty six have now passed away that's an
increase of four hundred and sixty eight
fatalities since yesterday
this new figure includes deaths in all
settings not just in hospitals before we
begin questions from the public and from
the media i wanted to remind people of
details of the next phase of our fight
against corona virus could we have the
first slide please in order to monitor
our progress we're establishing a new
covert alert level system with five
levels each relating to their level of
threat posed by the virus the alert
level will be based primarily on the
r-value and the number of corona virus
cases and in turn that alert level will
determine the level of social distancing
measures in place the lower the level
for fewer the measures the higher the
level the stricter the measures
throughout the period of lockdown which
started on the 23rd of March we
have been at level four thanks to the
hard work in the sacrifices of a British
people in this lockdown we've helped to
bring the our number down and we're now
in a position to begin moving to level
three in very careful steps slide two
please we've set out for first three
steps we will take to carefully modify
four measures gradually ease were locked
out and begin to allow people to return
to their way of life but crucially
avoiding a second peak that could
overwhelm the National Health Service
after each step we will closely monitor
the impact of that step on the are and
the number of infections and we will
only take the next step when we are
satisfied that it is safe to do so
step one from this week means that those
who cannot work from home should now
speak to their employer about going back
to work
you can now spend time outdoors and
exercise as often as you like you can
meet one person outside of your
household in an outdoor public place
provided you stay two metres apart slide
three please having taken the first step
in carefully adjusting some of the
measures and our advice to people we
have also updated what we're asking
people to do which is to stay alert
control the virus and save lives because
if everyone stays alert and follows
these rules we can control coronavirus
by ensuring the our number does not go
above one and reducing the number of
infections this is how we can continue
to save lives and livelihoods as we
begin as a nation to recover from
coronavirus I now want to turn to our
plans for the wider opening
calls at this time of year GCSE and
a-level students would have been making
final preparations for their exams while
other students would have been enjoying
their summer term if you're one of them
as I've said before I can only say how
sorry I am that this has all happened to
you this year
the sacrifices that you have had to make
through no choice of your own but the
impact that this coronavirus has had on
your life has made things so incredibly
tough for all of you it is now almost
eight weeks since we asked schools
nurseries and colleges to close for all
but a small number of children once
again I'd like to say an enormous thank
you to all the school college and
childcare staff who've done so much
going above and beyond the call of duty
to care for small groups of children of
critical for workers vulnerable children
as well as making sure that there's
resources available at home for children
to be able to learn and interacting with
them contacting them making sure that
children know that you are there for
them you have simply been outstanding
and we're so grateful for what you've
done we have been quite clear all along
that we would only start inviting more
children back into schools when our five
key tests have been met that position
has not changed nor will it and it is
what is guiding all of our actions but
we do want to see children back in
school because we know how much children
grow and benefit from being in school we
can now start for planning for a very
limited return
school for some pupils potentially as
early as next month let me explain how
this will work because I know that some
people including parents and teachers
are very anxious about this if a rates
of infection are decreasing it will give
us a green light to get children back
into child care and more of them back
into school from the 1st of June as part
of a cautious phased return those in
reception year 1 and year 6 will be
allowed back into school in smaller
class sizes we're also planning to get
some secondary schooled students back
those years in 10 and 12 to make sure
that their a had the opportunity to come
back to school on a limited basis and
have some face-to-face time with their
teachers we are prioritizing these
children because they stand to lose more
by staying away from school the first
years of school are pivotal for children
to develop social and behavioral skills
and to learn the basics that they're
going to have a huge bearing on how well
they do in their life students in years
10 and 12 were there facing the fact
that they're going to be sitting exams
next year and it's vital that we do all
that we can to help them succeed and
help them do well it's also particularly
important for vulnerable and
disadvantaged young people there are
some who would like to delay the wider
opening of schools but there is a
consequence to this for longer the
schools are closed but more the children
miss out
teachers know this teachers know that
there are children out there that have
not spoken or played with another child
their own age for the last two months
they know there are children from
difficult or very unhappy
for whom school is their happiest moment
in their week and it's also the safest
place for them to be and it's thanks to
their teachers and the support that
their teachers give to them that they
are safe they are happy the poorest
children the most disadvantaged children
for children who do not always have the
support they need at home will be the
ones who will fall furthest behind
if we keep school gates closed they are
the ones who will miss out on the
opportunities and chances in life that
we want all children to benefit from
from what teachers do for them and what
schools can deliver for them so we're
asking some children to come back from
the 1st of June and we're asking schools
to adopt a number of strict protective
measures this includes reducing class
sizes making sure pupils stay within
these small groups creating a protective
and small bubble around them schools
will also be rigorous about hygiene
cleaning and hand-washing school staff
can already be tested for the Viper
virus but from the 1st of June we'll
extend that to cover children and their
families if any of them develop symptoms
track and trace methods will then be
used for event the virus from spreading
together these measures will create an
inherently safer system where the risk
of transmission is substantially reduced
for children their teachers and also
their families my department has been
issuing full and detailed guidance on
how to implement these measures and to
prepare for wider opening we have worked
closely with a sector listening to those
who work in the classroom we will also
continue to do so to ensure schools have
the support that they need it goes
without saying that we will be careful
monitoring the impacts this first phase
has and we'll use this to guide us when
we consider our next steps
this phase return is in line what other
European countries are doing to get
their own schools colleges and nurseries
back I know a lot of you will be worried
about sending your children to school
every one of us wants the very best for
our children and I know how stressful
this time has been for all families
right across the country I want to
reassure you that this approach is based
on the best scientific advice with
children at the very heart of everything
that we do education is one of the most
important and precious gifts that we can
give any child so when we are advised
that we can start to bring some children
back to school we should do so so that
they don't miss out on the enormous
opportunities to learn to be with their
friends to benefit from everything that
their teachers and their schools can
offer them we owe it to the children in
order to be able to do that